I'm just kind of like okay and then
she's like kind of stalling some more
now the knock is getting like
like you know I mean like open and so
she goes to like look and she's like
it's him and I'm like who's him
[Music]
welcome back to another great great
episode great I love the careful boys
it's just so great luckily we have
christosa with us again today
question because I feel like this has
probably happened to some of you guys
and I know this has happened to me and
probably in some ways continues to
happen to me but what do you do
when somebody like let's say
what'd you do when something's wrong
with your face
I want to try to receive what was going
to come over here I thought your
allergies
I was about to ask okay imagine there's
a girl that you really like okay okay
okay
and you're a little bit chicken about it
so you never tell her and you don't
think there's any way this girl would
like you so you kind of just throw it to
the Wayside okay
then much later when you have a
girlfriend already she comes out of
nowhere and tells you
I liked you that whole time does she
still right now while you have a
girlfriend well that is to be discussed
because this is the line you're at now
what do you do when you're confronted
with that information that is sorry to
disappoint you Martha baby but the G
train has left the station
Steve told us a story
it's from the Grinch oh
it is it sounded like Jim Carrey yeah
yeah Steve told us a story where this
exact thing happened this girl he was
crushing on in high school
afterwards when he got into a
relationship she came and said that I'm
loyal to my sister and he just all he
did was say I'm loyal that's it yeah and
then um but it worked out for the better
I guess because that girl was a was a
complete mess or something so oh but
didn't that work out the other way for
him with Nikki
oh was it was she like with somebody
like at another time and then oh no
Steve was with somebody they were both
they were both with someone they were
both with someone and they both got
single at the same time or something
like that yeah yeah can I tell you guys
something sweet what
so I think this was like eighth grade or
something oh it's already Sweet it's
very sweet and uh our boy scout troop oh
got uh
we there's another boy scouts I don't
know why they have to come to our our
[ __ ] Boy Scout Troop but you know
like troops merge sometimes I don't know
why they they came into our [ __ ]
thing and then we're gonna merge troops
for some reason so I'm like okay this is
pretty cool there's a [ __ ] a bunch of
like 50 other kids and like grown men
and stuff that I don't know because
they're scout master comes to because
it's like the Boy Scouts is like a whole
like Community right you got kids you
got adults chaperones all that [ __ ] so
um I got cool with this one dude and uh
we started he and he became our
Assistant Scout Master and he has one of
those cool pads where like the dad has
like a man cave right in his upstairs
where there's like a pool table that's
so cool naked pictures of like chick
calendar man that's so cool darts that
kind of [ __ ] nice ass lazy boy yeah yeah
so all the dudes were like oh man this
assistant's gotta match is [ __ ] cool
so all the dudes started going to his
house all the time so they could see the
posters yeah see the posters Man's Cave
Man's Cave sure okay gotcha and then
what they didn't tell me what this guy
didn't tell me is that he had a sister
and then me and her we started talking
and uh we started talking through aim
and stuff and we got pretty cool and I
don't know how this Arrangement came to
be but we would meet up midnight like
like she was like from like I don't know
four or five blocks away we would meet
up midnight just to go toilet paper
people's houses
right delinquent love but that's not
even the uh what is it called like
that's not the theme the thing is that
we really enjoyed each other's company
and we did that for like probably six
months to a whole year no kissing no
kissing I just think that was so
enjoyable and maybe we're so in puppy
love that we
probably liked each other because the
amount of commitment of us meeting up
every midnight at [ __ ] until 2AM the
amount of toilet paper toilet paper like
every [ __ ] night we did this [ __ ]
and then I think one time
um
when I was over at their house like all
the people went straight to the man cave
but I was kicking it in her room with
her what did the friend say exactly so
all the older homies they go
ah Bart's in the Kohl's room what do
they gonna do I'm like what are you
talking about I was just looking for
something
so that that would like throw you off
too like I'm never gonna go in her room
ever again oh no cause I'm gonna get
made fun of got embarrassed away from it
yeah and so that was one that never even
came to be you know what's funny I
picture all these guys in the short
shorts with the [ __ ] scarf
the whole time with the [ __ ] Boy
Scout hat and
doing this like even when he's [ __ ]
toilet papering the house she's she's a
Girl Scout outfit that's a very
honorable dignified and manly outfit I
don't know what you guys are laughing
about it the short shorts with the socks
to the [ __ ] knee oh everybody looking
bored
damn bro wait till Dad that pulled you
guys apart because you were so
embarrassed well we still continue to
hang out but then it just nothing came
to be from it and then you know like
once you start going to like high school
then you have new friends new circles
new things and then so it would just
they just got older they're like at the
next TP house she's like so how come you
don't come to my room anymore
they're tossing and having conversations
he's got like three hairs on his beard
that's a good scene and then whatever
what if the whole time she that she was
a lesbian and Bart was her lesbian best
friend
you're in your own little friend zone
she's looking at that bar just like I
thought you were a girl so she never she
never came back in the future
no we just went like different you never
hit her up like hey you want to do
something at midnight
wow well never what if she came back
when she came back now
she had like a 36 roll of Charmin Ultra
dude she's just right here she hit it
above her head with like like the
Boombox like at your window
throwing throwing a TP at your window to
try to make a noise like a rock and
she's like for old time's sake let's go
holy [ __ ] he's like I can't I have a kid
now
playtonic tping
that was crazy I was that it was there's
nothing even happened from it it was
just like obviously we liked each other
no one could make a move we were both
scared and then
that's it okay I know you I know you got
stories Ryan what's up no I I was
curious if you guys did
it like you just have to like uh it's
just duly noted when they when well
because it's like if you really like
your girl you're in your relationship
it's like especially it's so solid it
wouldn't really affect you and and I've
had that situation but it's not even
from a girl I want so it doesn't count
like you're in a relationship
and then some girls trying to take you
away
but your girl's better so you're like
well thanks but I never wanted this you
know and you're so you're just thinking
I never asked for this Glory all right
I've been the guy I've been the guy on
the other side interesting like hitting
them and they'll be like I'm married and
I'm like oh okay cool congrats to myself
but it was like how come you didn't hit
me
before or like or like you like you
confess your love to them and they're
like you should have told me like a
month ago before I got married yeah it
was it was along those lines it wasn't I
didn't have like a full-on like
confession but it was just like a like
um checking in saying what's up and all
that stuff catching up but then they are
married and all this stuff and they have
a child and and it's like it was like
one of those like okay well she she
mentioned like why it was it was a
question it was in the air like how come
you didn't hit me like uh before and all
this stuff and I'm just one of those
like uh I mean
you got a family now what do you want to
do dude what if you weren't trying to
get at her and you're just trying to
actually just check in and say what's up
but then like you know sometimes girls
like they think oh this guy's probably
trying to hit on me so like oh yeah my
husband and like they always throw that
like oh my boyfriend this my husband
that to try to make it like yeah I'm not
available you know we didn't want to we
just wanted to say what's up it's like a
subtle thing but it's like what for the
sake of for the sake of your question
though like let's just say you were
thrown the situation like what would you
do
um if you're not married you're still
like in your dating phase I think it
depends on my age oh really yeah it
would like well I mean it might I think
20 is an on anyone that is a home
wrecker in my opinion like if they
already know you're in a relationship
and they're trying to pursue you
that already is a warning sign
because then I'm like uh it's a bad
trait it's a bad trait of that person
it's also you don't want to build this
start exact foundation on that type of
that's that's the last thing because I
always have the thought in the back of
my mind that when they get bored
or if anything happens wrong they're
going to look for another out but has it
ever been more innocent for you for
example like I feel like in high school
I didn't know I was home wrecking one
time that I might have been home
wrecking well yeah that's why I said
because yeah when you're innocent and we
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
you're just ignorant naive in your mind
you're just like I don't know what I'm
doing like we're just getting close you
know what I mean you start just spending
more time with your classmate that you
hang out with you're like oh I sit next
to this person or like you start like
doing group projects or homework
suddenly late night conversations turned
out to like Hangouts by the Boba spot
you know you're talking over Dale yeah
you're talking every day because you got
a new [ __ ] Nokia 3390 or whatever the
[ __ ] and you're holding hands and
everything and everything you just make
it out
actually doing home wrecking is another
that's pretty interesting too I don't
know I think I think it might be because
I saw my mom go through such a [ __ ]
hard time after my dad left that I think
early on since I was 14 it was always in
the back of my mind about
what happens when people get hurt and
then I don't could you see the aftermath
of it yeah like it's like uh because the
reason why he also left is he had an
affair so it wasn't just he hated the
situation it was just because you cut
his piano strings yeah it wasn't because
I [ __ ] up his piano there was a
multitude of things right yeah so then
that's a big one though you [ __ ] up
his piano yeah it's probably happened
he's like I can't stand him with his
piece of [ __ ] anymore
I cut my dad's pianos
chords yeah I opened up the back and I
got pliers and I just went beep beep
that's like the craziest thing wow bro
that's like your profession like you
know what I'm saying
I go into a harp and just like
yeah yeah yeah yeah just to see what
happens it was his project pianos in the
back though not his not his main one oh
wow oh he's like a penis Ryan you like
dancing I'ma break your ankle let me
snap your ACL all I'm saying is don't
put the pliers next to the pianos when
there's a child around oh tempting right
I had a situation yo where like I didn't
know I was uh I was I just got on uh uh
I was at the DMV and I was like renewing
a license or something like that and the
girl in front of me she was like getting
a license she moved from Indiana and she
was in Texas so she's getting like a new
license New State and uh I was in my
uniform back when I was a correction
officer so I was you know she's like she
like the man in a uniform situation we
were talking chopped it up got each
other's number and then we're texting
we're chopping it up we I you know oh I
can show you around Houston let's go out
to Sonata but I'm I'm also 18 19. I
don't even know Houston like that but
I'm just you know we're going out you
know she had a significant other at the
time she will we went to go eat we're at
the food court and she's kind of just
breaking down like yeah I did move out
here because I was in a relationship but
it just didn't go well and now I'm just
got my own apartment and this is and she
mentioned that it was a little abusive
and I was just like I was like oh man I
was like I was I was playing the
superhero role save her he was in
uniform you'll never you'll never go
through something like that you can
I think I even grabbed her hand like
across the the little table we're on
like you had to move the condiments to
the side yeah yeah yeah yeah hey get
this famous walk out of here you know
you know and she was just like you know
and uh we went after that like I was
like Hey like you want to go to like the
the pool hall after this like let's go
like shoot some pool and she was like
damn but she wanted to go by her
apartment first she wanted to change and
I thought that I was like I mean we're
already kind of like out but y'all all
right we go and uh I go I go in her
place and it's a little empty and she
did say she it was a new apartment
whatever and I'm in her room and uh
she's going back and forth from the
bathroom to the closet bathroom to the
closet and then there's a knock on the
door right and I was like uh okay I just
like whatever you know I need to paint
the picture are you still in uniforms
I'm not in uniform anymore what uniform
were you wearing this is just very
casual uni you know and so casual uni
yeah casual uni and uh uh she she didn't
acknowledge it and I thought that that
was weird so then the knock happened
again and I'm like yo there's someone at
your door that shows it's like it's all
good like that it's all good that was
like scariest answer that is dangerous
man yo and and I'm not a uniform either
I'm not I'm not I don't have I don't
have I'm just kind of like okay and then
she's like kind of stalling some more
now the knock is getting like
like you know I mean like open and so
she goes to like look and she's like
it's him and I'm like who's him and
she's like my ex the one who did this
and she's like showing like a scar I'm
like
why don't you show me that the food
court
the fingerprint is like this big
what the [ __ ]
and she's like she's like I'm gonna I'm
just gonna tell him that he needs to
leave and I'm like look at this
handprint
like that the one who did this oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh my God yo she's like I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell him he needs to
leave and I'm like no like I was like
don't answer the door like you know
what's gonna happen to you so imagine
what's gonna happen to me you know what
I'm saying like oh no and she she went
to like she she's still just like I'm
just gonna tell him I'm gonna tell him
he needs to go and I'm just like yo just
call the cops why does she want to
create a scene yeah and with you there
honestly I felt like I felt like it when
I thought about in hindsight I feel like
she thought that she found an officer
like she found a guy that can like
assess the situation that grabbed her
hand across the table and was like you
would never feel this again that's what
you told her that's what I told her what
if she [ __ ] lured him there so this
situation would go down saying all of
that is yes that's what I'm going with
you know I mean you over committed my
friend no I did this is all on me and
she she ended up like going to go answer
the door so whenever she went out like
for herself she got the chain thing on
the door though it was literally just
top lock and and oh no she doesn't even
have the team that you can't she's not
opening she said come right in did you
jump out the window no I literally when
she went to open the door I closed her
door and locked it I was like it's all
her for herself and I'm just but like
I'm this is I yeah in her bedroom you're
like [ __ ] her bedroom [ __ ] that yeah and
did you hear her get beat up
he was like where the [ __ ] is he at like
how the [ __ ] did he know heavy where's
he get like that like you I I heard us
ago I heard him I I know that there's a
dude in here his car is in the parking
lot says like Pimp My Ride type [ __ ] I
wasn't a big ass like yellow with the
Jeep I had a yellow 96 Jeep yo with
players lift [ __ ] wagon yeah yeah yeah
where the [ __ ] is he at and I was like
oh my God yo I was so tired and I and I
and I'm hearing like some like scuffling
and like and like you know like like he
hit the wall or maybe she he tossed her
or something it's going down you didn't
go I'm an officer
I was so terrified I even put like my
foot at the edge of the door just in
case the door stop just in case to like
you know like if you wanted to and and I
saw the door like jiggle like he's
trying to come in and I was just like oh
like I was I was so terrified but why
though you're a boxer because you I
don't like you know this man is is piss
you would beat the [ __ ] out of him no I
wasn't thinking that bro I was thinking
this dude's gonna murder me you need to
keep hand wraps on you so you can
[ __ ] rap this [ __ ] right here baby
I'm in here nah yo I was just like [ __ ]
yo how am I gonna get out of this [ __ ]
dude you're a loaded gun with no
gunpowder yeah pretty much I'm just a
prop gun I'm a prop good yo good you
want to whooped his ass it looked good
it looked good you would have whipped
his ass he's a gun loaded with empty
promises yeah
and then what happened I thought you
never gonna feel this again she's all
getting thrown around in the other room
I thought it was good until I I didn't I
didn't think I wasn't thinking her room
is connected with the bathroom so he
just went through the bathroom and went
through the second door yeah oh no
Meanwhile your foot's still on the front
door like oh [ __ ] I'm still here and
then I look over this way he got it and
he and he caught he's like like he sees
me and I'm just like I'm like this and
I'm like and he just goes and he was
just like I knew it and we went back to
go give her around two oh like I knew it
and took it out on her I was just like
oh my God yo I'm I I'm I'm ruined this
is all my fault is all this I'm [ __ ]
I like I do anything did that make you
feel stronger because he didn't attack
you bro I I felt I felt strong no cause
you know what I would have been like
wait you're not gonna hit me that means
you're a [ __ ] yeah you're gonna hit her
not me I'm not scared anymore yeah no I
was I it was I opened the door and I was
like this
you stepped over her oh yeah bro I was
out of there over her bloody body you
stepped over it he came over to me he
was like yo get the foot he was like he
came back to me like like pressing me
and I was just like hey bro this is none
of my business G like I didn't even know
she was even had like had a dude and
he's all just like you know get the [ __ ]
out of here all this [ __ ] oh but you
didn't know and she man look she was
like this she's like coming to me just
like dude I'm just like don't even oh
[ __ ] she was like like because I was
leaving out the door she wanted me to
not like not leave and I was just like I
I went like that to her don't even touch
me I don't even want to know
straight up I was out of there
oh hey
you got the [ __ ] Emperor's New Groove
in there though
was that dude like a grown ass man and
you're just yeah yeah he was a girl
he was like I give him like six two he
was like he was in uniform he was like
he seemed like he was like a card like
salesman like he was kind of in like a
in a fit like that but like were you
just scared or terrified because you
felt like it was fish out of water which
is the situation yeah it was like it was
for real like in such an intense like
you never had anything like that before
yeah hell no I didn't I didn't know like
at the first like when I got in my car
the first thing I did was call my pops
and now it felt so bad so guilty I had
like a little cry in my voice I was like
oh yo Pops I'm not a man pops I'm not a
man I didn't man up I didn't man up and
he was like yo whoa what are you talking
about I was just like yo like this
situation the shorty hadou came and like
put his hands on her and I didn't
protect her like I didn't do anything I
was like I froze and he was like are you
are you good that he have a weapon like
you you out of there I said yeah he's
like they you're good like that's none
of your business you know what I'm
saying he's like yo like you didn't know
what if he had a gun on him what if he
was like that day he was like if I come
to this and he's crazy man he's gonna
kill everybody yeah you did the right
thing that's true and you just met that
girl I didn't know yeah I have no idea
yeah oh you just met her yeah I just met
her at the DMV it's all the same day I
missed that part yeah I don't know yeah
no you thought that was like his girl I
had no business telling her this will
never happen to you will get like yeah I
don't know you don't even know his last
name and you told me that [ __ ] no no
this will never happen again Sasha what
was your last name yeah she's like it's
Sarah Sarah yeah yo it was like Sarah
Sosa that's it
well she knows he's unreliable
why I know right she's like man I
thought he was gonna [ __ ] back me up
dude he promised because the thing was
is like because like you said like it
seemed like it seemed like she set that
up to like maybe exonerate her yeah
because like she was ignoring the the
like and she was stalling from changing
why does she want to come to the crib
you know if you're already out yeah
we're already out she didn't really have
a fit to like switch into like it was
just like it yeah right so she you felt
set up it sounded like a weird setup
yeah like how did he know how did he was
he stalking watching waiting for someone
to come I didn't know to come home at
that time like it was just it was so I
think you did her a solid now she'll
know to never believe and trust nobody
but herself she's [ __ ] dead bro no
she's deaf
[Laughter]
oh you shall rest in peace don't be a
dumb 18 year old over promising the the
Pain's gone now
[Music]
[Music]